Charlie will be disappointed to hear
that his angels didn't make it to box
office heaven this past weekend
according to Deadline the film suffered
a dismal 8.6 million dollar domestic
opening and it only earned a paltry 20
7.9 million internationally across 26
markets beyond that the film had an
especially poor opening in China making
just seven point eight million dollars
in the lucrative overseas territory so
what went wrong exactly Charlie's Angels
seem to have a whole lot going for it
the film stars indie darling Kristen
Stewart up-and-comer Ella bilinski
alladin star Naomi Scott and the always
welcome Elizabeth Banks who also
directed the caper even the formidable
presence of Patrick Stewart wasn't quite
enough to help this film while according
to Deadline the lousy box office was at
least partially due to issues with the
script which reportedly underwent
numerous changes during development and
production there were apparently certain
pain points in the storyline that just
couldn't be fixed even with lots of
rewrites and it sounds like this clunker
of a script was a major turnoff to some
a-list stars as deadline reports the
script for Charlie's Angels didn't
really attract top talent like Jennifer
Lawrence Emma Stone and Margot Robbie a
trio that would have potentially jazzed
up business instead Sony brass chose to
relative fresh faces to star alongside
Stewart however bilinski and Scott might
have been a little too fresh-faced for
general audiences the fact that they
aren't quite household names turned out
to be a detriment rather than a drawing
point his deadline reports Stewart
herself may have caused the film to flop
Stewart who is hysterical in the movie
and even needed more funny bits is in a
different place in her career
professionally publicly and privately
it's unfair to think that she could
deliver her Twilight fans now after
years of appearing in arthouse films and
relatively low-key projects it's indeed
unlikely that Stewart would be able to
bring huge crowds to a film like
Charlie's Angels especially when she's
paired with new faces like velinski and
Scott but the film's grim box office
can't be blamed entirely on Stewart and
her fellow angels the film's action
sequences were admittedly lackluster a
fact that
seemed clear even in the film's trailers
and here's another question did anyone
even want a new Charlie's Angels movie
according to Deadline after Elizabeth
Banks expressed interest in taking on a
Charlie's Angels reboot with a modern
feminist spin there was no question in
Sony's mind that the project should move
forward sure it's been quite a few years
since Lucy Liu Cameron Diaz and Drew
Barrymore twerk to cross movie screens
in their own Charlie's Angels films but
that doesn't mean we were all chomping
at the bit for a brand new installment
in the wake of Charlie's Angels less
than stellar performance don't be
surprised to see a bunch of think pieces
claiming that female led movies don't
bring folks to the box office that
clearly isn't true after all hustlers
was a bonafide hit and it premiered to
great returns in September 2019 based on
a true story the film involves a bunch
of New York City dancers who built Wall
Street bankers out of their fortunes
fronted by an all-female cast and
created by a predominantly female
creative team hustlers earned an
impressive 33 million dollars on its
domestic opening weekend marking the
largest opening of Jennifer Lopez's
storied acting career there's absolutely
no doubt that movies created by women
and starring women can and will succeed
at the box office in the end the issues
with Charlie's Angels may have been
rooted solely in its script and
production but the middling 58% rating
on Rotten Tomatoes certainly didn't help
matters still it's disappointing that
the film is financially floundering
stars like Stewart and banks will
undoubtedly survive this career blip and
hopefully Belen Scott and Scott will
soon be given meteor roles to sink their
teeth into and who knows perhaps movie
execs will take a cue from Charlie's
Angels and realize that some franchises
just don't need to be rebooted remade or
otherwise freshened up Vince let's just
stop the touching some of these blows up
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite and not so favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]